um Sue gray could be serious questions
to answer for your boss this morning
over Sue gray and when he started
chatting to her
I don't think so I mean look we've
talked about this before okay the simple
truth is there's a process here it will
all be in the public domain eventually
any interest there is in this because of
the shocking Downing Street parties and
that led to the downfall of Boris
Johnson all of that will be in the
public domain there is a process this
committee looks at this it comes up with
a recommendation I see no reason to
interrupt that process or to comment on
it I think this will all follow that
normal course of action we've seen this
in the past another civil servants have
been appointed to various roles and that
really is is all there is to it and I
would just go back to the original thing
which many people will be aware of which
is of course is that sugary was not the
original person appointed to investigate
the party gate allegations that was
somebody else who then had to resign
from that process because they
themselves had been at these Downing
Street parties so I think we let this
process go about the way it normally
does and everything will be in the
public domain eventually it will
including the view from the government
excuse me which we'll hear later on
today and it's likely to conclude that
Sue gray broke the Civil Service Code by
accepting a job as kirstama's chief of
staff and it's likely that her
appointment will be delayed for
potentially up to two years
well look we don't know what is in the
statement uh that might happen today we
have to wait to listen to that frankly
when I hear these things what I hear
repeatedly is again conservatives will
never accept responsibility for their
own actions so even when a Downing
Street party Scandal has led to the
downfall of the Prime Minister they're
still always looking to blame somebody
else I think they'd be better off to be
honest just admitting their own conduct
at times taking some responsibility for
that but look let's see what they say
there's a process here it's going to be
followed that's the right thing to do
it doesn't pass this though does it um
is she worth all the hassle
again we are trying to do in the labor
party is take seriously the
responsibility that falls on us as the
only vehicle to replace what is quite
clearly a failing government at the end
of its time in office and we want to
prepare properly for that we want the
best expertise we want the best people
to do that and we want to follow
whatever correct processes there are to
hire those people I think there's no
more to the story than that and I think
everybody in this country should want a
political system where when you are very
close to a general election the polls
are as they are the opposition takes
that responsibility seriously we've got
a local election campaign obviously
going on right now where the main thing
people are asking is are they better off
after 13 years of conservative
government does anything work better but
can we take that responsibility that
opportunity seriously to replace the
government and responsibility is all we
are seeking to take properly forward and
I think having the best people working
with the labor party to prepare us for
this opportunity for this big election
coming up that has got to be the right
thing to do yeah yeah an election next
year and you might not have a chief of
staff
well I'm confident we will be ready for
that general election whenever it comes
I would like it sooner rather than later
because she won't be allowed to do the
job
well we don't know this we this is all
speculation we don't know why the
government believe as ever they need to
put these diversionary tactics all never
in place to try and change the story
when the story right now is there is an
election on Thursday the conservative
party has a dreadful record in office
people are quite rightly angry about
that we put forward in the selection our
policies for why we think we'd be better
for the cost of living and that's
getting support across the whole country
but fundamentally we will always seek to
hire the best people to build the kind
of capacity and team we need for that
big general election coming forward and
we'll follow whatever processes
correctly are in place in order to do
that
she might not be in post so you might
not have a chief of staff
um will you still give her the job even
if she can't carry out that job to the
best of her ability until a finite
period of time has passed be it six
months 12 months two years
okay there's nothing more I can say on
this the speculation that is in place is
is not particularly helpful we don't
know any of this for certain there is a
process to follow it's quite a usual
thing to happen there's nothing
particularly exotic about it this is an
independent process that will decide
what the time frame is and we will
respect and follow that and all of this
will will be fully transparent and in
the public domain but that's the story
and that's it and frankly the labor
party is seeking to hire the best people
should be something everybody welcomes
um you're certainly going to need a new
poll finding that Rishi sunak is a
better leader than um Zakir starmer 26
saying soon at 24 saying here starma
I've got to smile when I see the
reporting of this I saw some of the
headlines of this last night which
basically says people think this
government are failing not only on what
they think is important but what the
government thinks is important to it and
frankly to have a situation where the
Prime Minister slightly pulls up the
conservative uh pulling uh figures from
the absolute floor they were under in
that Dreadful interregnum with Liz
trust's prime minister where they
literally blooped the entire economy and
then pull slightly level with kirst
armor look I
be looking into that as they wanted I
can tell you from being in every bit of
this country for before Thursday before
the local elections the biggest thing in
this country is the cost of living is
people not being better off after 13
years of conservative government looking
around at public service and saying is
anything in this country better than
before the conservative party came to
power and I am confident in our leader
in our program that we are putting
forward as to why we will be better than
that and I think that is that is the
pull that will count Thursday's voting
long answers today let me ask you is
labor planning to scrap the um single
person's allowance on council tax
no no I understand there's a there's a
consultation uh that has taken place I
believe in Wales but this is not part of
our national plans for the UK labor
party and if we were putting forward
anything like that that would be
obviously part of a wider program of
Reform but the simple answer to that
question is no
uh and a quick thought before I let you
go BP 5 billion dollars worth of it's in
the first quarter
course year how much would you let them
keep
well we would do a proper windfall tax
which means taxing at the same rate as
Norway it means starting that windfall
tax from January 2022 when the windfall
began to be accrued and not having those
big allowances for new oil and gas
exploration and development and that
would raise up at 10 billion pounds
additional to what the government have
done we would use that to help the
economy and households overall which
would mean freezing council tax this
year and I believe what we've seen today
from The Profit figures from BP fully
validate the argument that we have put
forward and actually will be a far
better plan for the economy overall as
well as a fair one I want British
companies to make a profit but I want
where we've seen an unexpected windfall
for that to be shared more fairly and
that is the argument for a winfall tax
which I think has been reinforced today